let's continue with this example and i i
welcome you to throw examples my way and
we can think about whether something is
consumption or investment and my
argument in general is that investment
is something good for society it's good
for you it is capital right or money
that's being put to work to create more
wealth or more capital or more good for
society while consumption is capital
that is essentially being
burned in some way usually for some type
of social status or ego gratification
and and you know maybe maybe it is for
some type of um well let's think about
that what is what about a
a going out once a month let's say let's
say a vacation
this is an interesting case
a simple vacation
simple
vacation
with family
maybe it's a family reunion depending on
your family it might be that might be
simple or it might be relaxing it might
not but let's assume this is a a
relaxing vacation you know you're going
camping or you're going to yosemite or
something it's a very peaceful tranquil
thing to do so your original gut
reaction would be
well you know if i if i would take a
vacation me and my family we're going to
take time off we're not going to work
my kids aren't going to be in school so
you might say oh well that's consumption
because we're going to spend money let's
say you know i don't know the vacation
let's say it costs 2 000 right we're
spending 2 000 on this vacation
so that's that might be an investment
that's not or that might be consumption
so at first you might say that's
consumption you're not going to be
working once you go on that vacation
there's nothing left over but there
could be a counter argument here there
could be an argument that by taking this
simple vacation with a family it
re-centers you it bonds with your family
it makes you a happier human being and
it makes you more likely to be able to
contribute to society once you get back
home and if you didn't take this
vacation you would eventually burn out
so in this example it depends on what
you consider a simplification i would
con i would consider that actually
probably an investment especially if it
makes you more relaxed it eases your
brain it allows you to become more
creative and more productive for society
that that could be an investment that's
why i think it's important that you know
people don't overwork now
what if i were to um take me and my
family and we were to have someone carry
us i don't know or you know we we rode
on someone's back as they swam across
the ocean to go um stay in golden
thrones while a bunch of you know an
army of people danced for us right so
let's say an extravagant vacation
extravagant vacation
so you could argue a lot of things about
this is you know i have a family of four
unless it cost me two hundred thousand
dollars
two hundred thousand dollars
well here there's a couple things there
might be some part of this vacation that
makes you more relaxed and might make
you more productive i'd argue that it's
probably the opposite the extravagant
vacation is probably going to make you
more stressed and uh probably feed your
egos in ways that are in some ways
self-destructive but let's say there is
some component that is that you know
let's take the benefit of that that does
relax you and i would say that that
component is an investment but you know
what you probably could have gotten that
for two thousand dollars so let's say we
could say that two thousand of this is
something of an investment
and that ninety eight thousand dollars
or 198 thousand dollars of this
probably is consumption because it's not
making you more productive you know sure
enough it is when you go to this place
it is giving those people something to
do and it is um
it is giving them jobs but i would call
that a transfer of wealth this isn't
investment when you go to you know
whatever country you decide to go to and
you blow
essentially 198 000 that you didn't need
to just because it feels good to have
you know to have the locals um dote on
you
you're transferring money to them and
then you know maybe they transfer that
money to someone else but it isn't it in
no way is increasing the wealth of the
world it's not leading to innovation
it's not leading to more factories and
it's not leading to um
to to any type of the pie getting bigger
and you know what i don't even think
this is necessarily a bad idea because
frankly this is just a transfer of
wealth from someone who needs ego
gratification to a transfer of wealth
from someone who's willing to do you
know fairly simple things to essentially
take that wealth from them but at the
end of the day it is consumption
and i think you can imagine you know
like let's say a simple purse
a simple purse
you know my wife goes out and buys a
purse from target and it costs 20
is that consumption or is that an
investment well i'll argue that that's
an investment if she doesn't maybe her
old purse is falling apart by having a
new purse maybe it helps her get a job
be more productive maybe it helps her
get more organized so this could be an
investment
and what about a louis vuitton not to
pick on them in particular but what
about a louis vuitton purse
i don't know how much i don't know how
to spell it
a louis vuitton purse i think these cost
you know upwards of two thousand dollars
or or whatever
well this could clearly is is is some
form of consumption because it's well
you maybe make some argument that in
certain circles you could get a job if
you carry around one of these purses but
there's some basic
basic core value to it that you probably
could have gotten with a simple purse so
that maybe is twenty dollars of
investment
twenty dollars of investment and the
rest of it i don't know the other
one thousand nine hundred eighty dollars
is
consumption now ask you a further
question do you think that this is bad
or good for society
well i'd actually argue that it's
probably neutral for society because
it does look like a quote unquote waste
of money
this extra almost two thousand dollars
that you spent that you really didn't
have to to get something of a fairly
basic utility
but that those resources weren't burned
those resources went from
frankly someone who just wanted some ego
gratification it went from
someone's ego essentially so let's say
this is you or your ego
and this is louis vuitton
louis vuitton
the company
so you gave them one thousand nine
hundred eighty dollars that you didn't
have to
right their cost of making the purse
probably didn't cost a lot more than
that simple purse and in exchange they
gave you eager gratification so they
really didn't have to waste a lot of
resources they gave you all of this
brand imagery that makes you feel better
about yourself
eager gratification
so i would argue that not this capital
actually didn't get lost it just got
transferred from someone who was
probably a little insecure to someone
who knows how to sell to insecure people
and then louis vuitton will then have
that 1980 and then who knows maybe they
give that to their their private equity
friend or their venture capital friend
and then that gets invested in some you
know new startup idea that you know some
solar cell company that actually can
create energy from the sun and in which
case that money did not go wasted so
they might actually invest it in solar
so this actually was not a waste of
money although this transaction i would
agree is consumption i would say that
the waste of money is is all of the
advertising and all the sponsorship that
louis vuitton has to do to convince you
that this will make you somehow a better
person if you buy that that purse
because that those ads you see on tv
with those people you want to look like
that will not give you uh that that is
not creating any net wealth for the
world or it's not making the work the
pie any bigger
anyway let me think of a of another
example here well let's say so this
example with the louis vuitton purse
this is just a transfer of wealth but
let's say instead of doing that
you had your ego
and instead of buying a louis vuitton
purse you just so this is you
you thought it would be nice let me see
my phone is ringing
oh i don't know who that is i think it's
junk but let's say you thought it was
instead of buying a louis vuitton purse
which we established would just be a
transfer of wealth it is consumption but
at least that money doesn't disappear
let's say that you wanted to pay
two thousand dollars
to have you know i don't know let's see
ten dollars an hour you can have 200
people
200 people dance for you
200 people dance for you
dance for you
and recite your name and talk about what
an amazing person you are
this i would argue is pure consumption
because those 200 people
instead of sure this this money gets
transferred to them but they didn't do
anything productive with that time right
those 200 people they could have been
tilling the soil they could have been
working in a factory they could have
been teaching their children how to read
they could have been doing something
that was productive for society but
instead they spent one hour dancing for
you for for your ego gratification
and this is in my mind the worst form of
consumption because not only it's it's
not just a transfer of wealth it is a
destruction of wealth because though
200 people's time is wealth that is
capital that is capital that could be
used to improve someone's lives but
instead this two thousand dollars was
essentially destroyed sure it goes to
those people right but at the end they
didn't create anything in that amount of
time and i'll touch more about that
anyway in essence the amount of money
didn't change in the system but the
amount of value in the system got
degraded because all these people's time
got wasted and in the end that actually
leads to inflation if you have more
money in a system with less productive
goods and services you have more money
over less productive goods and services
so the price for a productive good and
surface goes up
but anyway i'm out of time again but i
encourage you to think as much as you
can about just this idea where when you
spend money is it consumption or is it
investment and then i'll continue this
more into kind of a lot of what the
government tells you to do when the
economy goes down how they say hey go
buy yourself a nice dress instead of
saying hey why don't you go build a
factory or why don't you save your money
and invest in your child's education
anyway see in the next video